[Music]
if she sees someone that looks like him
it's the same thing that she just kind
of goes into this panic as much as you
feel comfortable tell me about sexual
intimacy y'all good thank you oh that's
fantastic
sorry uh we party brother no don't be
don't apologize
[Music]
what are you doing welcome to the dr
john delony show
i hope you're having fun
hope you're cleaning something running
from something
i guess not running from running from
bad health towards good health hope
you're exercising up you're driving to
work whatever's going on maybe just put
a podcast on to drown out your three
little ones screaming their heads off in
your house whatever you're doing i'm
glad that you're with us i'm glad that
you joined us
uh man we are so grateful that you are
here if you want to be on the show give
me a shout at
1-844-693-3291 that's
1-844-693-3291 or go to johndaloni.com
ask let's go
straight to the phones let's go to grace
in saint george utah what's up grace how
are we doing
i'm good how are you i'm having a blast
what's up in your world
so basically i am a
resident assistant at my university
and
i've had a resident lately who has been
having
um like really severe mental health
issues
and um my boss has basically just asked
me to like keep checking in on her
and everything um but our university is
super understaffed um in the counseling
office but i don't really have anywhere
to refer her to
and so basically it's been falling on me
to like check in on her but
i mean the first time i checked in on
her i had to call the emergency line
because
um she told me she was having
hallucinations and like intrusive
thoughts that were suicidal
and
um basically i just don't really know
uh
how to be a friend to her
um and also make sure that i'm
protecting myself yes and making sure
that i'm not getting hurt
you're you are very wise how old are you
grace
i'm 20. good for you you are wiser than
many many many folks twice your age so
good for you i'm glad that you are in
that role
um
lots of stuff here
let's
try to figure out where to start here
um let's start with
just the state of the r.a position
so
i
how'd you find this show let me ask you
that
oh well i guess i still i've listened to
dave ramsey okay and i took his classes
in high school so
um through the ramsay show and you
thought you would upgrade and elevate
and you you found our our show here i'm
so glad that you're here um so for those
not listening the resident assistant the
r.a position
um is
the live-in position so it's usually an
undergraduate student sometimes a
graduate student who lives in the
residence hall
with
college kids
and it can be a fun job but it is an
exhausting
frightening thankless job
and usually they way underpay you and
they give you room and they give you
like a free place to live which is great
it's awesome but that comes with 24 7
365
emergency care
mental health care
often you've probably held students who
are vomiting because they drank too much
and you're
getting barfed on or bleeding whatever
it comes with so much stuff and so it's
24 7 365.
um and then situations like this
so um grace tell me about the student
when you say having some significant
mental health challenges you mentioned
the student is
suicidal saying like i'm thinking about
hurting myself um
they've talked about they're
hallucinating tell me what else is going
on in that in the life of this student
yeah um so when she talked to me she
said that she like hadn't gotten out of
bed for three days
and she said like
her thoughts are like she's like they're
not like my own thoughts
um
but she's still having them like she'll
have thoughts telling her to hurt
herself but she's like i don't want to
do that
um and then she's also having
hallucinations
um and her parents aren't real
supportive
and again the university doesn't really
offer what they say they're gonna offer
sure um
so
so
here's here's where universities have
found themselves and having been in this
exact role
um
i'll tell you here's the challenges
colleges have found himself
they've really found themselves in a
no-win game here's why
um
when someone has a mental health
diagnosis it's an ada 504 issue okay so
you can't treat somebody differently
because of their disability
so you can't make a student who
is
challenged with mobility who gets around
in a wheelchair
you can't say well you can't be a
biology major because that building
doesn't have a elevator so sorry you got
to pick from our other majors you can't
do that you can't treat them differently
you it's responsible you're responsible
for providing accessibility to the to
the biology lab to the classrooms
and so
when you get to mental health issues
like this they become really messy
really fast because i can't tell a
student you have to leave my college
because then i'm treating them
differently
i can't tell a student you can't
have access to this part of the campus
because i'm violating their disability
at the same time
there's there's court cases where a
student took their life
they died by suicide and the school was
held liable
and so now schools have found themselves
in this weird um and for a season there
was a few years where they used the
the disciplinary the student conduct
code as a way to get rid of students to
say hey you are no longer safe to this
environment to this community you have
to leave which then they successfully
sued that you're violating my my
disability rights you can't kick me out
because i have a mental health issue and
so now schools are like what do we do
and then you throw in the massive
financial issues that many many many
schools are having across the country
and then you get to where you are grace
where
you're a 20 year old undergraduate
student who's
trying to get your
degree
and you're an r.a and then somebody
unbelievably like i'm visibly um i'm
trying to talk a little bit too much
right now because i'm i'm angry on your
behalf
that anyone would ever tell an
undergraduate student hey just check on
them
and you've got somebody who has said
i've got voices in my head tell me to
kill myself and your supervisor would
say well just um
just um just keep an eye on them
right
oh
man
so here's a few things that i would do
if i'm in your situation number one i
need you to know that that's an
unethical response that it's an
unethical situation you've been put in
the middle of and i hate that for you
um
it's never the responsibility of a
student employee or a paraprofessional
employee to deal with somebody who says
i'm going to kill myself that's when the
adults in the room have to show up okay
um
so i'm sorry that you've been put in
that situation the first thing i would
do is
you look in the mirror i need you to
hear me say this directly
this is uh major psychiatric issues that
go well beyond my capabilities
okay so if somebody came into my office
and told me what that student has told
you which has happened i can't even
count how many times that exact
conversation has happened
i even with all the training and
experience i've got would take that
student and make sure they were in
contact with on or off campus resources
okay
so that's not your job right now but i
need you to hear me say you can't heal
there's not a thing you can say to this
student that they're gonna go oh
there's not a um
this has exceeded your ability right
your capacity and so i need you to make
sure that you are not feeling
responsible for this student's
well-being their mental health issues um
we are we are into psychiatry territory
now okay
that's hard for you because you're
somebody who helps you wouldn't even
have this job all right do you feel
yourself trying to take this all on
a little bit yeah okay um more so i've
just been worried about like
not taking it on like
really trying to like not
um not feel responsible okay all right
so the second thing i would do is um put
in writing
what you've experienced and make sure
that
your
director of residence life the the
assistant dean over housing or however
your whatever your thing that they have
that in front of them and
that's going to include your resident
hall director
okay and there's going to be some sort
of you're getting me like you jumped the
line or you should not have sent this to
this person you should have sent it to
me the resident director and i the hall
director and they i should have sent it
this is a point where somebody has told
you i'm hearing voices and they're
telling me to kill myself
so i'm calling in all the cavalry
calling in everybody
you know what i mean and if somebody
fires you for that oh
your lawsuit will be incredible okay
so okay um i would put in writing
i need everyone to be on the same page
with this
this student has said the following
and i feel unequipped to be responsible
for the mental health care of the
student
let them
be take over from there my guess is you
will probably get some sort of heat for
sitting that email okay and here's what
i want the reason i want you to send
emails i want you to put it in writing
that you as a 20 year old have been
asked to well you just check on them and
let us know how things are going and
that you feel increasingly ill-equipped
and unprepared for dealing with a
student who has said i'm hearing voices
and i'm going to kill myself
okay
and so if heaven forbid something does
happen you can say i put everybody on
notice
that i was not equipped for this and
this was not part of my job
also the school many schools have
students who exceed their capacity for
care that's normal it's the school's job
and i've had to have all kinds of
conversations throughout my career
to get off-campus resources lined up for
their students if they're telling their
parents
that
we're taking care of your kids and so it
should be
if the counseling center doesn't have
care great it should be that there's
partnerships with local hospitals local
mental health resources local
psychiatric units and things that we can
send this kid to sounds like your
college does not have that is that right
they do
sort of
um but it's like the on-campus one is
supposed to be free and so then when
they were for people off campus and they
have to like make sure that they get it
covered and insurance and things and i
just don't know how supportive her
parents are and
okay all of that so so what i would tell
you is this unfortunately
some people and you've dealt with this i
know you have have crummy parents
they have parents who don't show up or
they have extraordinary parents who
simply don't have the financial means
they don't know what to do next
and
it's really hard when you love somebody
and you care about them to be frustrated
about their parents but that's not
something that you can handle that's not
on you okay
hopefully
hopefully
you have a dean of students or a vice
president for student affairs who's
reaching out to the parents saying we
have a major major situation here your
child is not okay they are threatening
to hurt themselves in our residence hall
they're hearing voices and we have to
get them the care they need and i can't
tell you how many times i've made that
phone call in my career
so it's normal it's part of the job it
should happen
and there does come a moment when the
students care needs do exceed the
capacity of the institution to help out
and that's when the 504 the the
disability services office and the dean
of students that's what everybody
partners together for what we do next
um
and their job is to partner with the
parents not yours
okay
and
it is okay to care and the best way you
can care for this student this young
woman is to make sure everybody knows
how serious this is
um is every are you confident that
everybody knows the status of this deal
i i would think so
um when i call the emergency line then
um they bring in like some sort of um
like assessment team and they assess her
for risk and um and every time they've
just been like well she's clear okay
so here's the thing this is gonna be
hard for you
just trust the team because that's their
professional job
and you might think oh no oh no the
student may be telling you one thing and
then another that's why writing down
having it writing is important but if a
team comes in trust the team
as hard as that is trust the team um one
other thing you might do is um
contact somebody in the counseling
office that you have a relationship with
whether it's one of the staff therapist
or the director of the counseling center
and write them an email too and say this
student has continued to tell me
that they're suicidal that they're this
that they're this that they're that
can you please give me a few tips on
what i should do when they say this
and again you're letting another
professional in your world understand
exactly what's going on here
and final thing keep calling
if you call 9-1-1 and they show up and
they clear somebody and they leave and
it happens an hour later call 9-1-1
again and then call 9-1-1 again because
that's the only tool they've given you
is this is this number right to call
this assessment team
um
i will also tell you this this is hard
to hear
i have worked with i came to hundreds of
ras in my career and sometimes ras
because they live with the students
because they really care deeply
they feel like they've got more insight
than anybody else they feel like they
actually are the ones who know more
and so i would trust the professionals
in the world around you
that's hard because you're going to feel
like you aren't doing anything
they may not be doing anything for a
reason so
send the emails make sure the adults in
the room know exactly what's being said
exactly what's going on keep caring and
care by passing this information along
and then trust the professionals in your
world oh that's such a hard job being an
re thank you for being brave and
courageous and for leaning into people's
lives and for everybody listening make
the call make the call
most of us are not equipped to deal with
this kind of stuff make the call we'll
be right back
do you want a better life a better
marriage better mental and physical
health the single most important action
you can take to improve your mental and
physical health to change your entire
life
is to get enough deep restorative
quality sleep i know this from research
and as a guy who has struggled with
sleep for my entire life
and for me good sleep starts with a
world-class mattress that's why my
family sleeps on dream cloud mattress
dream cloud is advanced technology and
you can buy it in the store or you can
do it like i did and have it shipped
directly to your house dreamcloud is
running their biggest offer ever
exclusively for dr john dolone's show
listeners 399 bucks and accessories plus
an additional 250 discount that's a
total of
649 dollars in accessories and savings
pillows mattress protectors luxury
sheets all of it it's time to stop
sleeping on your old college mattress or
the old hand-me-down from grandma and
start changing your life visit
dreamcloudsleep.com or dream cloud sleep
and enter promo code deloney and get
your new mattress today
all right
i guess i should have said all right all
right all right but
the mascot of texas already has that
line he stole it he didn't steal it he
made it he made it up literally made it
up let's go to nolan in the opposite of
texas texas alberta canada what's up
nolan how are we doing
hello what's up nolan
hey thanks for taking my call of course
brother thanks for calling what's up
um so my mom is getting remarried this
may okay
and i'm not sure how i should be
handling this because
i want to be happy for her
but the situation's kind of bothering me
so tell me about it
um so my
parents separated almost 11 years ago
okay
and i was
12 at the time
and i'm 23 now
and my mom has been with this guy
for three years
and uh prior to that she was single for
seven years
and um
now she's going to be marrying this guy
and he's a really nice guy but
i've come to realize that
this is kind of the peak of
my parents never getting back together
ah
so that um that's a common
common story that kids tell themselves
is it may work out again
especially as there's a little bit of
space between the divorce um the actual
pain of the divorce and not the pain the
pain goes forever that the the
proceedings of the divorce
and then parents start being more civil
and they even become friends again
and there's always this running
narrative that maybe they're going to
get back together
oh man that's hard so it sounds like
your mom was single
stayed single long enough for her to be
able to dote on you until you left the
house is that about right
yeah that is correct wow what a what a
noble woman loneliness is brutal it is
brutal
um tell me about your relationship with
your dad
um my relationship with my dad is
we're kind of close in some areas but we
don't have deep conversations together
okay how come
um
uh well
we've never been able to kind of
form that that bond after the separation
why'd they get separated why they get
divorced
uh so my dad he had an affair um
with somebody that i knew
and your mom said i'm out
uh well my dad it was my dad's choice to
leave because he was had his eyes on
this other woman instead of my mom
are they still together
um
no my dad is not together with that
woman but he has somebody else now
and they are engaged okay
oh
man um i don't know if anyone's ever
told you this they probably have i don't
know if you believed him
that divorce wasn't your fault nolan you
believe me when i say that
yeah
many people have told me that and
i i want to believe it but sometimes
it's hard i know
and there's a 12 year old in there
that's still trying to figure out what
in the world you did to split them up
and i hate that for you yeah because it
wasn't on you
and there's part of you wondering with
everybody you date and everybody you go
out with when's it gonna come when are
they gonna leave you
and every time you get close to somebody
who's a
male role model you keep wondering when
they're going to leave whether it's a
boss or a supervisor or coach or
something like that
and
it's hard to trust your parents even
though you love them
and so you've just kind of been
untethered and the story's been the
thing that's held you together and now
the story is for sure haven't appeared
at the end of it right and this whole
thing's hard yeah
brother what's not your fault
and i hate this for you
i hate this hate this hate this and
divorce is so common
that
we forget how devastating it is
man i hate this for you brother
so
the real challenge here is how to own
the past right
how do you own what happened how do you
make sense of what happened and then how
do you get on to what comes next
and so the question i'll ask you is
while you're healing and while you're
starting to write something new
what do you want tomorrow to look like
man because this has haunted you for
half your life
yeah i just
i just want to make the most of my life
and
not repeat the cycle okay so
uh that's real like highfalutin language
i want to make the most of it what does
that actually mean
um
i think i just want to
honor my parents and
and you know love them and not
not judge them for for their past things
and all that and i want to have a good
relationship with my family okay
and um i just want
to i want to be successful in whatever i
do in my life okay
here's what's so hard about divorce
is
you plugged into that relationship and
that relationship unplugged from you
and if one of your goals is to have
great relationships with your family
that's noble and the idea is great but
it takes two to have a relationship
and
you can spend tons of energy and
passion and excitement and
all that stuff trying to make
relationships work with people who are
not interested in having relationships
with you
this is gonna be hard for me to hear to
tell you i don't mean to back on your
old man but it's his job to connect with
you
he's your dad
and he chose not to
and that sucks
the reason you don't have deep
conversations with your dad is that he's
never had them with you
you're his kid
it's his job to set up an environment
where you feel safe enough to talk to
him where you feel safe enough to
challenge him to ask him hard questions
to push him on things him to push you on
things him to ask you hard questions him
to call you and say what are you doing
why are you wearing that
those are only
true and noble and accountable
conversations if there's a relational
context and most kids go their whole
life asking themselves what did i do
to my dad that was so bad that he
couldn't give me that
and that's why it's so important from
you to hear me say that wasn't on you
man
and you've got to make peace with the
fact that that that relationship may
never happen because of him
because he chose for it not to be
you still respect him you still honor
him you don't talk crap about him you
move on with your life
but at some point you have to stop
beating yourself up over a relationship
that wasn't yours to hold on to it was
his
do you believe me when i say that
yeah yeah i do believe that and it's
hard i know it's hard so let me paint
you a picture of what the other side of
this can look like
your father dishonored your mom
and then instead of
healing that dishonor
he bolted he left he took off on her
left her high and dry alone he left you
you got brothers and sisters
yeah i have two younger brothers yeah he
bailed on his three boys
and mom
duct taped that thing together your
mom's pretty awesome
yeah she's great yeah
she's probably not perfect that's hard
the the amount of loss and trauma and
then raising three knucklehead boys is
hard right i can only imagine that
um and then here she is
and so
if you can wrap your head around this
hard concept this the your parents
marriage is not a reflection of you
them not getting back together is not
the signal that ultimately you failed
because you had nothing to do with their
relationship
you can be devastated you can be
heartbroken you can be
like pissed off all those things are
good
the whole things are right all those
things are noble it's how you act on the
back end of those things and so
what your mom looks like is she took a
long route and she
doubled down on you guys and she finally
said i'm not going to be lonely anymore
and she found as you put him a great guy
a good guy
which is incredible
i would begin
honoring that
and hear me say this
the discomfort you have in honoring that
doesn't mean it's wrong
does it mean that it's um
that you're somehow you're going to feel
like you're betraying your dad
i want you to put that nonsense down
you're not betraying your dad you're
loving your mom
and this guy who's going to take care of
your mom he's a good man sounds like
he's a good guy
he is going to give your mom peace and
he's going to give your mom connection
and he better not cheat on your mom
right he's going to be the guy that
stepped in that gap that your father
left
and
here's what i would recommend you do and
if you've listened to the show i've said
a thousand times i would write your dad
a letter that you're never gonna send
him
and tell him everything
how heartbroken you are how hard you
tried
ask him why he never connected with you
ask him what was so bad about his son
that he left him
what's so bad about those little
brothers that he just took off on him
and then i want you to write your 12
year old self a letter
and say dear 12 year old me
remember the house you grew up in
remember that house remember the school
you were at
talk about some of those details to help
to bring that that memory back and then
i want you to let that kid off the hook
and say hey you've been fighting for me
for 12 years now
it's time for you to go play
it's time for you to go have fun
because you got dragged into an adult
fist fight and you were not prepared for
that fight
so when i say those things nolan like
how's that
does that ring true to you or does that
sound like hogwash
no that rings true for sure okay write
those two letters and then here's your
third letter okay it's your third
homework assignment
that letter to your dad may be three
paragraphs it may be 25 pages
okay
a letter to yourself maybe five
paragraphs it may be 25 pages let that
stuff go and you may want to talk to
that little boy a couple of times
because he's been fighting for for you
for a long time
and then the last letter i want you to
write that you're going to actually send
is to your mom
i want you to tell her how brave you
think she is how strong you think she is
that this new marriage is going to be
hard but that you are in her corner and
you love her and you you're going to try
to love this new guy and you're going to
respect him
and that
you're going to ask for her to be
graceful with you cause the whole thing
is kind of weird but you are fully in
you're in mama's corner just like she's
been in yours
i want you to wrap your head around that
write that letter and then actually send
that one
but a big chunk of that is is to thank
your mom thank her for sticking around
when dad bailed thanks for raising you
three little crazy crazy kids
for making sure you all had food and
clothes
and for never walking out on you
because mom took the hard path
does that sound good
yeah sounds good all right brother nolan
will be thinking about you man
hey in that letter with this
make sure your mom saves a dance for you
at her wedding
that way you don't have to say anything
you all are just going to dance you're
going to hug
you're going to put your big old 23 year
head
23 year old head on her
little bitty shoulder
and you all are going to dance like you
haven't danced in about 10 or 15 years
you're worth that dance she's worth that
dance we'll be right back
you all know there are lots of things
that make me nuts but one thing makes me
more nuts than anything else
buying a home and my friends who
refinance their homes they tell me it
makes them nuts too
i love living in a new home but i gotta
be honest
i'm no good at buying one and that's why
i'm so thankful for people like my
friends at churchill mortgage churchill
is a ramsey trusted provider who we've
been sending people to for over 20 years
to help with home mortgages why
because they're committed to doing
what's right for you and that means
walking you through paperwork that's way
over your head that means making sure
you get the right mortgage that you can
pay off as soon as possible and then
i'll try to upsell you a bunch of
nonsense that's going to hurt you down
the road and most importantly when
you're making this big life change you
can actually
breathe because you got an expert in a
team who have your back listen if you're
about to buy a home and make a big
change
save yourself the headache and call
churchill mortgage today at triple eight
loan 200. trust me that's triple eight
loan 200.
this is a paid advertisement mls id 1591
nmls consumer access dot org equal
housing lender 1749 mallory lane sweet
100 brentwood tennessee 37027 programs
are for select loan types only and are
not available in all states or locations
all right we'll take one more call let's
go to jake in sacramento california
what's up brother jake
hey thank you for taking my call dr john
how are you i'm good man how about you
doing all right doing all right um
well i i have an issue so my wife um is
a survivor of domestic violence uh from
a prior relationship of course um
and she has um
a lot of things that cause like
triggering events for her
so
i just wanted to know how i can best be
an advocate for her during that time
what i mean what i can do you know try
to help her get past that i know it's
gonna take a lot of time for her to heal
and
she may always have that kind of issue
but yeah what can i do to help her man
she's lucky to have you
it's awesome thank you
um how long you've been married
oh boy um
going on five years okay so tell me
about
um triggers and episodes and what
happens
yeah so um if we go to like a certain
part of town
where some of these
things took place she'll kind of like
panic and get real quiet and
if she sees someone that looks like him
it's the same thing
she just kind of goes into this panic
and kind of
closes into herself if that makes sense
won't say anything just kind of freezes
um
if she feels like she's stuck like let's
say we're in the bathroom getting ready
together in the morning
i noticed this when we first got married
she would kind of do the same thing so
now i intentionally
get ready on the side where i'm kind of
stuck in the room and she has the
right next to the door you know sure
um
so just kind of those
things what about a certain
we can't go to certain restaurants
yeah certain restaurants we can't go to
like the ski park
up and north of us and you know just
stuff like that
um man
okay
um tell me about as much as you feel
comfortable tell me about sexual
intimacy
all good thanks oh that's fantastic
sorry uh we party brother no don't be
don't apologize awesome that's what we
waited until we were married okay you
know
no it's been amazing cool okay
um
all right so
i'm going to say some things that are
going to people are going to have
comments on and that's fine
um
but
i've just
man this one's close to home for me and
so i'm gonna be pretty direct okay
okay
number one your wife's lucky to have you
um most
partners can be not most many partners
can be insensitive to this um they don't
care or get over it or deal with it
whatever and it sounds like you are
interested in your wife feeling safe and
your wife being well when i think that
she is lucky to have you good for you
i'm glad that that's your impulse and
that's your heart that's so good
thank you um so
here
the basics of trauma is this her body
remembers these stories remembers the
location of these stories members the
guy who
um hurt her in the past where she was
hurt what was happening when she was
hurt the environment
and her body is now like if you think
about like terminator 2 one of those
scanning things with like the red
you know
night goggle vision right those red red
lights she's just scanning the
environment 24 7 365 for the next time
she's gonna get hurt
and her body's identified locations
people you know um uh
meal like whatever like all this
environmental stuff all the ecosystem
stuff
and
when it when she finds herself in these
places
and she can't run she can't fight it
she's learned you just go numb right
we're gonna freeze we're gonna shut this
sucker down
and
here's the hard truth
you can like you were doing be really
careful about environmental triggers you
know this part of town's no bueno i'm
not going to this part of town these
restaurants aren't good this um
we're not going to the hockey game cool
we're not going hockey game you need to
stand on this side of the bathroom cool
i'll stand on that side of the bathroom
those kind of things you've been really
accommodating for
those are avoidant those aren't healing
right okay
ultimately
your wife is going to have to decide
that she is not going to live under an
identity of ex-survivor
that she is going to
say i survived x
i lived through it
now i'm going to be about the healing
journey that comes next
and lucky for her there are some
incredible trauma treatments
right and i do think given what you just
explained to me i do think she needs to
get with a trauma counselor
um and some of these things might take
years some of these things given her
partnership with you given that she's
got a safe home
man some of these things may be 12 or 14
sessions
and that's it
and here's what trauma counseling does
it teaches you
ways to begin to take control back of
your own body
i'm going to control my breathing i'm
going to do these two or three things
when my heart rate takes off on me
i'm gonna learn these um
body safety things and then
with the help of a therapist
after three four five six sessions we
are then gonna go back through the
trauma narrative and here's why i'm
gonna do that
i'm gonna take these new tools i have
about how to let my body know that we're
safe now we weren't but we are now
and we're gonna stop our bodies from
telling this old story in the present
through you know diarrhea through
vomiting through shutting down through
getting silent through getting scared
through clenching all those things that
trauma survivors experience
and we're going to go back through the
trauma narrative we're going to tell
that story
until this exposure right until
my body stops taking off on me or when
it does i know how to take care of it
we're going to things like exposure
therapy we're going to go to the other
part of town and we're going to have
these new tools
and we're going to breathe through the
when we were in this part of town 10
years ago eight years ago we weren't
safe now we're safe
now we're okay
and this is a process but it starts with
her deciding i want my body to heal and
here's where that's really hard number
one we live in a culture that gives
identity to the worst thing that ever
happened to you that becomes a who we
are
that we live out of
and the second thing that makes this
really hard
is that type of thinking in our minds
and in our bodies keeps us safe it kept
us alive and what we have to know is the
things that work to keep us alive then
are slowly killing us now
and that's a hard shift
it will feel for a season like she's
losing control like she is intentionally
putting herself in harm's way
and that's where those new things we
learn about how to breathe through
things how to roll with things how to
instead of clamming up to reach over and
grab your hand how to lean into that
discomfort when we're surrounded by
people that are keeping us safe that or
that or have our safety in mind and then
slowly the body goes oh yeah we're good
we're good now and then two years three
years down the road you'll be in another
part of town and she'll have forgotten
about it and she'll be like oh oh look
at this we're in this part right
that's gonna take some work but she's
gonna have to decide that
right here's where this is here's go
ahead oh sorry she has gone to several
counselors
a lot of them
say that they can't do anything a lot of
them have broken down crying in the
middle of their sessions which is
interesting
hey that's sort of that sort of empathy
i'm okay with
but you can't talk your way out of
something that somebody beat into you
right
there's no amount of oh okay
this is something that you have to
practice
and
whether it's tfcbt or whether it's emdr
whether it's some of these things tfcbt
is usually with kids but there's some
great great counselors who can help so i
would
specifically ask for somebody who is
skilled in
seeking safety skilled in
trauma counseling
that what's frustrating for me is when
you get with a good trauma counselor the
healing can be not always can be
relatively fast a couple of months
six or seven months three or four months
maybe a year and so if there's systemic
abuse that went over years and years and
years from your parents and sexual abuse
some of that stuff will last for years
and years
some stuff can be healed quicker if the
therapist knows what they're doing and
if you have a client who's willing to
jump in with both feet
but
just traditional let's just sit down and
talk about this
man
that's that is there's some literature
that suggests that's re-traumatizing
because your body's re-experiencing this
but you haven't given your body any new
tools on how to deal with it
that's why i'm so such an advocate of
writing stuff down that's why i'm such
an advocate of breath work that's why
i'm such an advocate of moving your body
letting these stress chemicals when they
set off letting them have a place to
cycle through and not just get stuck in
your body and loop and loop and loop and
loop i'm a huge fan of emdr i'm a huge
fan of body movement therapy right
um there's there's a lot of modalities
if you get a trained person in your
corner and i hate hate hate that you
guys got somebody that was
didn't know what they were doing or they
didn't stop and say hey i need to pass
you on i've got a reference of three
people that can help specifically with
this sort of
um physical abuse trauma i hate that for
y'all please don't give up on
therapy just because y'all got a couple
of bad apples okay
yeah no no no she's cool she's been
actively looking cool so here's what i'm
gonna do i'm gonna send you a copy of my
new book on your past change your future
case i want you to hang on the line i'm
gonna send it to you for free it's my
gift
and you all read that together and okay
there are sections in the book on trauma
the whole book is about about empowering
people to say you know what i am worth
what comes next
and while we do walk through it it's not
a substitute for trauma therapy but i do
believe it will really really help
somebody in their journey as they're
walking out of something like this okay
i appreciate it also it'll help you
because i know this is hard for you and
people don't talk to those
people talk enough about loved ones who
love people who have experienced trauma
and some of this rubs off on you and
some of this you begin to look in the
mirror and be like am i just worthless
what about me and then you feel bad for
thinking what about me is am i right
yeah yeah spot on okay so um i want you
to read this book too because y'all read
it together and it would be really cool
if you all read this together and you
read a chapter she read a chapter and
then y'all had some time to talk about
it or you had a journal that you kept
between the two of you and you wrote
about what you thought in chapter one
and then handed it to her
and y'all go back and forth and you'll
keep a dialogue going and for someone
who's experienced trauma
the act of saying it out loud can be
brutal so having a place to write it
down might be a great
thing for you two to do together
and then my goal is if i've done my job
at the end of this book you're both
on the same team ready to take on the
world and when you get there man healing
becomes a way of life it's not this big
scary
um overwhelming thing okay
okay so hear me say this there's there's
a bright light at the end of the tunnel
and for your wife that light is a
it's the size of a ballpoint pen
and
hold her hand through this and i think
y'all are going to be in
heading in a good direction
therapist listening to the show
if somebody comes into your office
do not ask
do not ask for the trauma story in the
first session or the second or the third
or the fourth until you've equipped them
with some skills some things they can
practice
because when they start down that road
and their body takes off on them it's
traumatizing to just sit in your office
and have a discussion about what
happened to you in the past
without giving them any tools
it's unethical don't do that it hurts
people and i also know because i've been
there
a client walks in and says hey you're
not going to believe what happened and
you literally want to know i'm curious
stop them and say
there will be time in this session to
hear about the assault the rape the time
that somebody beat you within an inch of
your life someone that you loved
there will be time to tell that story
that's not today
we're gonna do some work so that when we
go down that road
when we're ready for that when you're
ready for that
then we'll be able to go through that
story together and i'll be right here
with you
and you'll have some tools on how to
deal with it
please be a therapist of integrity and
if you're not equipped to deal with
trauma you better get equipped quick
because that's the 22nd century the 21st
century and all the people coming over
from the 20th century that's our job now
get equipped get equipped take every ceu
you can read every book you can get all
the trainings you can learn how to be a
trauma-informed therapist start today
we'll be right back
do you feel like you're always busy
doing something lists chores work stuff
kid stuff pet stuff all of it but you're
never getting anywhere in the areas of
life you really care about like in your
relationships with friends taking care
of your body connecting with your spouse
a romantic partner loving your kids
then it's time to look at the things
you're doing and how your actions are
keeping you from where and who you want
to be
if your actions aren't working for you
anymore that's okay
now is your chance to get up and choose
differently and that doesn't have to be
complicated in fact in my new book own
your past change your future will walk
through a common-sense approach to
mental health and wellness including
steps to change your actions and move
you closer towards the person you want
to be
johndaloni.com to start creating the
life you want that's own your past
change your future at johndaloni.com
all right we are back as we wrap up
today's show don't forget to go check
out my new book own your past change
your future go to johndaloni.com
please pass this uh podcast on to
somebody you care about
or if you don't like it to send it to
somebody you're not friends with that'd
be hilarious
um but please uh leave reviews do all
the stuff um to help us out man the show
is just continuing to blow up and i'm so
grateful for you
um today's song of the day comes off a
record that i loved when i was a kid and
i just saw it came out in 1989 which
means i'm a thousand years old
the song is off the real thing record by
faith no more a band that i loved as a
kid man these guys jammed songs called
falling to pieces and it goes like this
back and forth i sway with the wind
resolution slips away again
right through my fingers back into my
heart where it's out of reach and it's
in the dark and sometimes i think i'm
blind or i might just be paralyzed
because the plot thickens every day and
the pieces of my puzzle keep crumbling
away but i know there's a picture
beneath an indecision clouds my vision
but no one listens because i'm somewhere
in between my love and my agony i'm
somewhere in between my life has fallen
to pieces somebody put me together
that's what this show is all about
keeping us together we'll see you soon
coming up on the next episode he told me
in a nutshell that i'm super
argumentative and even went as far as to
say is like i'm emotionally abusive
towards my wife
i've been looking into fertility options
and potentially considering
a sperm donor we haven't been intimated
in probably five or six years why for
five years
have you never brought up to your wife
hey we haven't had sex in
1500 days good gosh this is a lot okay
[Music]